president of the United States
please have a seat do you think about
press here
well good evening everyone
for turning the important work we
accomplished here at the G7
I want to take a few minutes addressing
the budget negotiations that I'm heading
back home to uh to deal with
before I left for this trip I met with
all four Congressional leaders
and we agreed the only way to move
forward was in a bipartisan agreement
I've done my part
you put forward a proposal to cut
spending by more than a trillion dollars
on top of the nearly three trillion
dollars in deficit reduction that I
previously proposed through the
combination of spending cuts and new
revenues
now it's time for The Other Side to move
they're from their extreme positions
because much of what they've already
proposed is simply uh quite frankly
unacceptable
and so let me be clear I'm not going to
agree to a deal that protects for
example 30 billion dollar tax break for
the oil industry which made 200 billion
dollars last year they don't need an
incentive another 30 billion dollars
while putting health care of 21 million
Americans at risk by going after
Medicaid
I'm not going to agree to a deal that
protects 200 billion dollars in excess
payments for pharmaceutical Industries
and refusing to count that
while cutting over a hundred thousand
School teachers and and assistance jobs
30 000 Law Enforcement Officers jobs cut
across the entire United States of
America
I'm not going to agree to a deal that
protects wealthy tax sheets and crypto
Traders while putting food assistance at
risk for nearly a hundred well assuming
nearly 1 million Americans
it's time for Republicans to accept that
there is no bipartisan deal
to be made solely solely on their
partisan terms
they have to move as well
all four Congressional leaders agree
with me that that default is not let me
say it again default is not an option
and I expect each of the I expect each
of these leaders excuse me to live up to
that commitment
America has never defaulted never
defaulted on our debt and it never will
the speaker and I'll be talking later on
the plane as we head back because it's
what five or six success at seven
o'clock in the morning there and our
teams are going to continue working now
we've had a uh we've had a packed few
days here in Hiroshima and I think with
very productive important meetings at
the G7 Summit
we also held the quad meeting here in
Hiroshima rather than Australia an
important bilateral discussions the
primary sheet of Japan prime minister
Albanese of Australia and president
zielinski of Ukraine as well as the
prime minister of India this is my third
trip to the indo-pacific as president
and I look forward to rescheduling my
stops in Papua New Guinea and Australia
later
spoken with the prime minister of Papua
New Guinea and secretary Lincoln is
traveling there to meet with the Pacific
island Partners at that moment and I'm
also going to be hosting and I've spoken
with the Prime Minister hosting the
leaders of the Pacific island Forum in
Washington this fall because unable to
make it to Papua New Guinea and the
Prime Minister Albanese we're going to
have a state visit later this year and I
also want to thank president kashida for
his outstanding I'm not it's not
hyperbole he's outstanding leadership of
the G7 this year as well as Mrs kashid
and the entire Japanese government for
the hospitality they've shown to Jill
myself and our whole team
being in this city and visiting the
memorial on Friday
was a powerful reminder of the
devastating reality of nuclear war
and our shared responsibility to never
cease our efforts to build for peace
and together with the leaders of the G7
we have read it we have reiterated our
commitment to continue to work toward a
world free from the threat of nuclear
weapons
over the past few days have showcased
the unity the unity of purpose among the
G7 it's a very different organization
than it was five seven ten years ago
because we're addressing the challenges
that matter most to the world
we're United in our efforts to
strengthen Global Health security
and yesterday I announced that the
United States plans to contribute
another 250 million dollars to the
pandemic fund at the World Bank to make
sure the world is better prepared to
prevent detect and respond to Future
pandemics
we're United in our commitment to
climate action and accelerating the
transition to a global clean energy
economy by investing in the industries
of the future
we're United in our push to build a more
resilient and inclusive global economy
that can better withstand the kinds of
shocks that we've experienced over the
last few years including by building the
more secure and more Diversified supply
chain
through the partnership for Global
infrastructure and investment which we
launched last year at the G7 Summit in
Germany and we've addressed the
infrastructure needs that are holding
back too many low and modern income
countries particularly in the global
South
the United States has already mobilized
more than 30 billion dollars in pgii
projects around the globe a significant
step toward our our Collective Pledge of
the G7 to mobilize 600 billion dollars
in investment by 2027.
and we've resolved to reform the
multilateral development Banks to begin
the more flexibility and better able to
fight poverty by helping respond to
Global challenges
now we're also United in our approach
the People's Republic of China
and the joint statement released
yesterday outlines the shared principles
we've all agreed at the G7 and Beyond
dealing with China
we're not looking to decouple from China
we're looking to de-risk and diversify
our relationship with China that means
taking steps to diversify our supply
chains and we're not so we're not
dependent in any one country for
necessary product
it means resisting economic coercion
together encountering harmful practices
that hurt our workers means protecting a
narrow set of Advanced Technologies
critical for our national security
those elements are all agreed on by the
G7
finally
joined here in Hiroshima by President
zielinski and the G7 reaffirmed our
shared and unwavering let me say it
again our shared and unwavering
commitment to stand with the brave
people of Ukraine as they defend
themselves against Russia's brutal war
of aggression and the war crimes being
committed together with our partner
countries we reiterated a need for just
peace that respects Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
both core principles of the UN Charter
Russia started this war
and Russia get ended today by
withdrawing his troops from Ukraine
internationally recognized borders and
cease its assault
until then excuse me the ability
Ukraine's ability to defend itself is
essential to being able to end this war
permanently and through diplomacy you
know and this morning I once more shared
and assured president zielinski together
with all G7 members and our allies and
partners around the world that we will
not waver
Putin will not break our resolve as he
thought he could two years ago almost
three years ago we're going to continue
to provide economic humanitarian and
security assistance to Ukraine so it can
stand strong as long as it needs it and
today the United States announced our
latest tranche of artillery ammunition
anti-tank weapons and bridging equipment
to help Ukraine succeed in the
battlefield
you know in my private meeting with
president zielinski after the G7 meeting
and with his staff I told the United
States together with our allies and
partners is going to begin training
Ukrainian pilots and fourth generation
fighter aircraft including F-16 to
strengthen Ukraine's Air Force as part
of a long-term commitment to Ukraine's
ability to defend itself we provided the
last year all that they needed to deal
with what they were dealing with at the
moment and that's when now we're moving
in the direction of putting them in a
position to be able to be defend
themselves in ways beyond what they've
had to deal with so far
the past few days have once more
underscored how important America's
Global Leadership is presumptuous thing
for American president to say but I
think you'll find if you ask any of our
colleagues it's true the security and
prosperity of the American people are
substantially increased by working in
concert with our closest allies and
partners to build a future
of Greater economic strength and
resilience in a world that is more
peaceful and stable
and on many of these issues that matter
to the American people accelerating our
clean energy transition preventing
another pandemic dealing with China
standing up for Ukraine the meetings
I've had with my fellow G7 leaders have
left us more united
more resolved the more determined to set
up for the greater progress in the
months ahead
and this has been an extremely
significant and important Summit
with that I'm going to take some
questions and uh
Trevor of Reuters
a moment ago What You Won't Do in terms
of your negotiations with Republicans
but I'm interested in what you've
signaled you already might do
in particular by conceding in these
negotiations to some form of a cap or
freezing spending are you concerned that
Mr McCarthy has already forced you into
accepting a policy position that could
tip this economy into a recession
no I don't believe that's the case at
all as a matter of fact I think that uh
we can reach an agreement as I've told
you and you may be aware you've seen it
we have provided for a
proposal that would cut a trillion
dollars off the Baseline spent from the
year before by just the green to deal
with what was initially offered and
secondly we're in a situation where the
let me put it this way if you all were
doing your budget at home
and you said okay we have to make some
cuts
would you only look at the spending
would you also look at your income
what was coming in the door to determine
what you could afford
and so part of what I've been arguing
from the beginning
is a need to consider the tax structure
as well as as well as cutting spending
I'm willing to cut spending
and I propose Cuts in spending of over a
trillion dollars
but I believe we have to also look at
the tax revenues the idea that the my
Republican colleagues want to continue
the two trillion dollar tax cut that had
profound negative impacts on the economy
from the Trump Administration
the fact that they are we've provided
for the number we've got a lot of input
from serious economists and former
Administration officials in both parties
that we need more people who are
qualified to be able to look at the tax
returns of the Thousand billionaires in
America very complicated stuff it's
estimated that if we had the appropriate
number of tax tax Personnel that we
would save somewhere between we would
generate so somewhere between 200
billion and 400 billion dollars in tax
revenue
and there's a lot of other for example
the idea that we're in terms of uh taxes
that they refuse to for example we
was able to balance the budget and pass
everything from the global warming Bill
anyway I was able to
cut by 1.7 billion dollars in the first
two years the deficit that we were were
accumulating and uh because I was able
to say to it that the 55 corporations in
America that made forty four hundred
billion dollars or 40 billion dollar 400
billion dollars that they uh they had
paid zero in tax zero
and so we said you got to pay a minimum
15 taxes what a horrible thing you're
paying more than 50 percent of taxes
every one of you out there and so guess
what we not only balance the budget we
we were able to reduce the deficit by
1.7 billion dollars and so there's a lot
of things that they refuse to look at in
terms of tax generation
as well as what kind of people were
going to increase taxes for like I said
we're now down to we went from somewhere
roughly 740 billionaires to a about a
thousand billionaires in America they're
paying an average tax rate of eight
percent
raise your hand if you want to pay eight
percent only I think you'd all be ready
to do that so my point is that there's a
lot of things that they refuse to
entertain and they just said revenue is
off the table
well revenue is not off the table and so
that's what I continue we continue to
have a significant disagreement on on
the revenue side
I know they will
I know they won't matter of fact
the fact that we were able to uh
uh cut government spending by 1.7
trillion dollars that didn't cause a
recession that caused growth
look we have the the lowest unemployment
rate in over 50 years we've created 12
point I think it's 7 million new jobs
including 800 000 manufacturing jobs we
have moved in a direction where we're
rebuilding and reconstructing America
through the through the the
infrastructure Act
look here's the other thing
I'm sure I'm not sure my guess is I'll
get a question about you know well wait
a minute you know
the American people aren't satisfied
well guess what as I've told you all
before most of this what we passed
doesn't kick in oh it only kicks in over
time
and so the fact is for example that if
you're in a situation where you were
I'll give you one example but I've used
everybody understands easiest is insulin
well I decided that we were going to be
in a position where we were not going to
continue to pay the highest drug prices
in the world and that's what we do by
the way same manufacture of a drug in
the United States selling it here in
Japan selling it in Tokyo or selling it
in Berlin or selling in around the world
they pay a lot less than we pay at home
so we said a simple proposition let's
take a look at how much it costs to make
the product
and I'm not going to ask you to show a
hands like you're doing a town meeting
but if I usually ask how many people
know somebody who has Type 1 or type 2
diabetes and I'm almost at least half
the audience raises their hand
well they were paying somewhere between
four and seven hundred dollars a month
for their insulin that they badly need
to stay healthy and Alive well guess
what it costs ten dollars ten ten
dollars to make
pack
age argue maybe as much as thirteen
dollars well guess what now they can't
charge more for Medicare can't because
Medicare is paying taking American tax
dollars and paying for the elderly's
health care needs you can't charge more
than thirty five dollars for that that
drug that saved 160 billion dollars
here 160 billion dollars less will be
paid out by by the American taxpayer to
help the elderly people on Medicare with
a problem
well a lot of this is just kicking in
we're in a situation where next year
for the drug cost no senior will have to
pay total cost
total cost of all the drugs from
expensive Cancer drugs to whatever drugs
they're taking will not have to pay more
than 3 500 a year
the following year we've already passed
this as a law now
the following year they wanted to pay
more than two thousand dollars that
saves another 200 billion dollars that
we're paid now but the other team won't
count this even though it's the law we
passed it they won't count that as
reducing the debt
so there's a lot of those kinds of
disagreements we have and my guess is
that I'm going to be talking to uh
to uh the speaker of the house on the
way back on the plane because there'll
be warning time over at home and I'm
going to be in that plane about an hour
or so and my guess is he's going to want
to deal directly with me and making sure
we're all on the same page but that's
probably more than you wanted to know
um
how about
macero and NHK
good evening Mr President
the Chinese military is more active at
this time in the Taiwan Strait with
expectations this might increase leading
up to taiwan's presidential election
next January
despite uh despite uh some you know
diplomatic communication recently
between the U.S and China
the military hotline is not working
under this circumstance how will you
manage
data diplomatic you know relationship
with China and how will you strengthen
the U.S alliance with Japan and are okay
in order to counter China thank you well
now number one you're right we should
have an open hotline
the Bali conference that's what the
president she and I agreed we were going
to do and meet on and then this silly
balloon that was carrying
two Freight cars worth of spine
equipment was flying over the United
States and it got shot down and
everything changed in terms of talking
to one another I think you're going to
see that begin to thaw very shortly but
in the meantime
what's happened is I think it's fair to
say for those of you who have dealt with
dealt with the Japanese government and
reported from here for a long time
the situation in terms of our relations
with Japan have never ever ever an
American history been stronger never
never
and we started this relationship when I
came to see some of you with me by my
first trip here when I came to see
president the president president's
predecessor and made the case that was
happening in Europe it's a small the
world's getting smaller what's happening
in Europe and the invasion of Ukraine is
affects everyone including people here
in the Pacific basin and so we've ended
up where you have Japan stepping up in a
way that's of real consequence in terms
of your defense budget number one
and a beginning of a reproachment with
South Korea
I've spoken at length with President
loon of South Korea he came to
Washington of late he's agreed for all
of the same agreement that in fact we
are not going to we're maintained we all
agree we're going to maintain the one
China policy which says everybody kind
of forgets no I mean you all know but
the public kind of forgets that it says
that neither country Japan I mean China
or Taiwan
neither territory can independently
declare what they're going to do
period there has to be a mutually agreed
new outcome and so we're sticking by
that we're not going to tell
China what they can do when we made it
clear that we don't expect we don't
expect Taiwan to independently declare
independence either but in the meantime
we're going to continue to put Taiwan in
a position that they can defend
themselves and there is clear
understanding among most of our allies
that in fact if China were to act
unilaterally there would be a response
there would be a response but I so I
don't think there's anything inevitable
about the notion that there's going to
be this conflict between the United
States and the west and or Japan and
Korea and the quad and if you take a
look at what's happened
we are more secure with all the talk
about China's building its military
it is building its military and that's
why I've made it clear that I am not
going to prepare I'm not prepared to
trade certain items with China and when
I was asked by President XI y I said
because you're using those build nuclear
weapons and other weapons of mass
destruction and I'm not going to do it
and we've now got commitment from all of
our allies they're not going to either
provide that kind of material that
allows them to do that but that's not a
hostile act that's an act that says
we're going to make sure that we do
everything we can to maintain the status
quo ending and what's going on now is
the look at the meeting we had here
today uh today and yesterday on the quad
did I bet you I would maybe some of you
thought it but I doubt many many people
in this audience or any other audience
would have said that two years had to be
elected I'd be able to convince India
Australia Japan and the United States to
form an organization called the quad to
maintain stability in the Indian Ocean
and the South China Sea
well when asked by the Prime Minister by
uh for president XI why we're doing that
I said simple we have an international
organizations have agreed upon what
constitutes open airspace and sea space
and we're not going to allow that to be
unilaterally older period
we're not changing any rules we're just
making sure that we unite democracies in
the conviction that the Pacific Basin
remains what it was before open and
clear so I guess what I'm saying is I
don't guess what I'm saying what I'm
trying to say is I think we're more
united than we've ever been
ever been in the Pacific in terms of
maintaining stability and and
maintaining a sense of security
so
I'm not sure that answers your question
but I hope it does if it doesn't you
want to follow up with any portion of
that question
well how about uh
if you don't want to follow how about
Anne Marie a Bloomberg TV and radio
thank you Mr President you just said I'm
willing to cut spending speaker McCarthy
says that the U.S government needs to
spend less next year than they did this
year so will you agree to that and on
China your team has been trying to
secure meetings with their Chinese
counterparts would you consider easing
some sanctions to improve relations like
the sanctions that are currently on
China's defense minister thank you
yes and no
no I'm not going to need the sanctions
but yes I think we should uh on the
front end of your question is that we
there's a lot that is going on relative
to spending
and we have agreed to cut spending we've
cut spending and we're going to continue
to cut spending but the question is what
base do you start from
initially if you remember when the
Republicans introduced their
when the speaker
by I guess a four or five vote majority
was able to pass his what he calls
extending the debt with a limitation on
how what you had to do to expend it in
terms of the budget side I said I'm not
going to negotiate on whether the extent
of debt I will negotiate on the budget
on the budget side of the equation that
came along and said initially it was
hard to determine where they are quite
frankly and I don't know you all may
know more from questioning than I do but
they came along and said we're going to
move off of the
2023 budget
and that's the Baseline we're going to
use for the next two years that budget I
said well what about what you all just
voted on after the budget which was the
add-on money that you you all agreed to
on the house in Santa voted for
and they said well that includes that as
well
I said okay well then we may be able to
work on something so we started
calculating what that would mean in
terms of it can't do a 22 percent cut
for everything in the budget but the
things that have already been passed the
five big initiatives that I've already
passed in terms of
infrastructure the Affordable Care Act
that said cetera
but in the meantime
what happened is that uh
that seems to be changing they said well
we're going to exempt remember we said
that well you're going to cut veterans
because 20 who said everything or this
discretionary but so no we're not going
to cut dutches okay that's good and we
initially they started off they're going
to cut Medicare Medicaid no I mean not
Medicaid
Social Security and Medicare I said no
no no
first time I ever had a negotiation in
the State of the Union message uh but
they said no we're not going to cut that
okay well that's all awesome radar what
else is off the radar and they name some
other things and I said well that means
if you want to get the number you wanted
from freezing the budget at 2023 plus
the additions you added then that means
you're going to go from 22 percent
you're going to end up cutting 30 or 35
discretionary budget for example if you
calculate what they're talking about
they're going to lose they're going to
lose a hundred thousand teachers and
assistance they're going to lose
thousands of police officers across the
board I mean just calculate what it
means if you take all discretionary
spending
and you'd make no distinctions other
than what the percentage number the cut
is and some of it makes absolutely no
sense at all
and so what we've done is we're going to
have to sit down I'm hoping that uh that
uh speaker McCarthy is just waiting to
negotiate with me when I get home which
has been I don't know whether that's
true or not we'll find out but at first
we weren't making progress then we made
a lot of progress and then all of a
sudden we came back to the proposal that
was very cut back from where they'd
agree or discussed and now I don't know
where we gave a counter proposal to the
counter again I know this sounds
ridiculous but that's what we did and
I'm waiting to hear the response to what
we have offered
we are willing to cut spending as well
as raise revenue so people start paying
their fair share again a physicist for a
time meeting to ask raise your hand if
you think the tax structure is fair
remotely Fair what do you think
anyway so that's the context
no I know that that's under negotiation
right now I thought you said whether I
lived sanctions on material I was going
to send the seller defense department
meaning would I sell some the answer
that's under discussion
um Jim tank is the New York Times
Mr President thank you oh um you speak a
lot at these Summits about the power of
democracies to solve big problems uh but
I'm curious in these meetings with world
leaders how are you explaining the
possibility that American democracy
could cause a global financial crisis if
the debt limit is breached next month
and I'm wondering if you are offering
them assurances that whether it's by
invoking the 14th Amendment or anything
else you will take whatever steps you
need to make sure that doesn't happen
first of all
it would be a very serious circumstance
if we didn't pay our debt for the first
time in 230 years
that'd be a serious problem
so far
there's been very little discussion and
they all know what's going on about
whether or not we're going to default
during a day
number number two number three I can't
guarantee
that they wouldn't force a default by
doing something outrageous I can't
guarantee that
number four I'm looking at the 14th
Amendment is whether or not we have the
authority I think we have the authority
the question is could it be done and
invoked in time that it could not would
not be appealed and as a consequence
pass the date in question and still the
fall of the debt that's a question that
I think is unresolved and so the point
is I think I'm hoping and I believe that
when we stood in that we sat in the room
with all the leaders from Mitch
McConnell on
and they said we will not default period
we will not default that should all
including Kevin McCarthy said we will
not default
and so I'm assuming that we mean what we
say and we'll figure out a way to not
have to default
um
Elizabeth Palmer CBS News
good afternoon Mr President
um what has president zielinski told you
about the big counter-offensive and
maybe you can start by telling us
whether it's actually underway or not
and I also I'd like to ask you about the
f-16s you've greenlit them now Jake
Sullivan said arms and Equipment go to
Ukraine uh according to what he called
the exigencies of the conflict so what
exigency now exists that didn't exist
that demands these planes
well I'll tell you exactly when they're
going to move exactly where they're
going to go he told me come on God I
love you I'm going to even if I knew
precisely you think I'm going to tell
you what they're going to do in terms of
their offensive
well I hope you hope I wouldn't do that
because that would mean it wouldn't
succeed
but the fact is that um we did discuss
privately
with uh with the one I did discuss
how what we put this way
we and our NATO allies know how many
brigades they have trained know what the
status of those brigades are and have an
expectation as to what their likelihood
of succeeding are
we don't know that for certain war is
uncertain war is uncertain not to State
the obvious
so
and my it will proceed I can't if even
if I I think I do know but I'm not going
to tell you because that would not be a
smart thing to do either
so having said that
uh the expectation and hope is that
they will be successful in that it'll
make it clear to Russia that the cost
for for example
Bach mood is a discussion about whether
or not has been lost or whatever
and well the truth of the matter is the
Russians have suffered over a hundred
thousand casualties in Buffalo
it's hard to make up
so whether or not there is there are
troops in Buck mood occupying there's
not many buildings left standing in
Black Moon it's a pretty devastated City
but they have been able to move in a
direction that they've been able to lock
down an awful lot of the Russian forces
including the Wagner group
so
with regard to the f-16s f-16s would not
have helped in that regard at all it was
unnecessary for example let's take this
for example would not have any any
additional added consequence but what's
happened is
since the Provo the provision of
everything from
the
significant missile defense systems uh
tanks sophisticated tanks and like all
the things that were of consequence in
the near term in the dumb boss area and
where the fighting was taking place they
now have all that equipment there's a
little bit still coming but have all
that equipment what's going to happen
though is if they continue to do well
they're going to be in a situation where
you're going to have the Russians being
able to stand off at a greater distance
for maintaining their headquarters and
other things which are out of range of
certain of the existing capacity they
have and we have to be able to be in a
position where now those fighter jets
those f-16s make a big difference in
terms of being able to deal with what is
coming down the road and God willing and
we don't know this if they're successful
and there ends up being an accommodation
where there is not a cease-fire but
there is a peace agreement that gets
worked out that they'll have the
capacity to have
confidence in their ability to resist
response by the Russians if they were to
change their position so that's the
essence of the difference
it was another part of the question
no not the percent I don't expect the
f-16s that take
part in the existing let's assume that
it's not but let's assume tomorrow the
offensive was started
or in a week or two or five or seven or
ten it's not highly unlikely they would
take place in that context
but it will take place in the context if
they're successful in the near term
they're going to then continue to have
to fight with the Russians who have have
headquarters Beyond where they are now
not able to reach by the existing
capacity that exist in their Arsenal so
it's a different need just like the
tanks weren't needed in the beginning
but they're needed now and so that's
that's the nature of the change
where's that
I have a flat Assurance from the from
zielinski that they will not they will
not use it to go on and move into
Russian Geographic territory
but wherever Russian troops are within
Ukraine and the area they would be able
to do that thank you all very very much
appreciate it
it is for them
nobody
feel of course no blame me I know you
won't you'll be saying Biden did a
wonderful job
I I know you
on the merits based on what I've offered
I would be blameless on the politics of
it no one would be blameless and by the
way that's one of the that's one of the
things that some are contemplating
I actually had
well I gotta be careful here
I think there are some
major Republicans in the house
who know the damage that it would do to
the economy
and because I am president and
president's responsible for everything
Biden would take the blame and that's
the one way to make sure Biden's not
re-elected
thank you
thank you everybody
we have not come up with the unilateral
action
that could succeed in a matter of two
weeks or three weeks that's the issue
so it's up to lawmakers but
My Hope and intention is when we resolve
this problem I find a rationale to take
it to the court to see whether or not
the 14th Amendment is in fact something
that we'll be able to stop it thank you
press conference has concluded thanks
everybody
thank you everyone